joining us now is a dynamic duo heading
into a zombies treaquel everyone welcome
meg donnelly and milo manhattan it is so
much for having us so good to see you
too i have been asking you zombies
questions for three movies now
it's very rare for a film to have
a treequa how does this feel
it's absolutely insane i can i think i
speak for both of us when i say when we
were shooting the first one we didn't
even think we were gonna do a second one
but then just to see the reaction to the
first one and the second one i mean
having a third it's a like there's not
very many movies that have done this
before so it's a historic thing we are
going to be together forever
in this third film your characters are
it's their senior year of high school
a lot of nostalgia
yes what what ensues senior year of high
school
well
that's a loaded question
as
zed my character he's trying to get into
college mountain college he would be the
first monster to ever attend so it's
it's really important that he gets in
but another yes another really important
reason is because if he doesn't get in
it's possible that that's the end of
zedison you know zed and addison might
not be able to be together anymore but
that's where we pick off with zed
and then with addison it's kind of the
same thing she's already in college um
so she's just trying to write out his
senior year still doing cheerleading the
big cheer up is coming up um but again
very nervous that you know zed might not
get into college as well and then when
the aliens come that's when things start
to change a lot for them yeah you'll
have to watch to find out oh no
we have a problem what is the lesson
that you want fans to take away from
this film well obviously throughout the
whole franchise there is an underlying
theme of acceptance but in this one it
really focuses on the importance of
conflict because that that leads us to
conversation which which leads us to
grow and progress as a community so i
think that that's something we really
hammer home on this one we need to find
their most precious thing they're here
to take what's ours
i love that rupaul is involved with
zombies three it's quite we were
freaking out we figured that out the
zombies three group chat was going crazy
yeah but we personally haven't met him
yet we hope to very soon but what a
fitting cat right yeah when we were
filming we had no idea who the voice of
the mothership was gonna be at all so
that was like added in after and we
freaked out yeah you gotta make an
impression why is rupaul perfect for
this role well okay when you when we
were shooting the mothership
lines were usually just read by some
random person off the screen but um when
you re-watch the movie and you hear the
flair and pizzazz
it just brings the movie all together it
really does yeah we're all trying to
chase the bright lights of hollywood and
live our dreams how has this franchise
helped you know
establish that platform to elevate you
guys in the next level in your careers
because you guys are both booked and
busy outside of zombies yes michael
start with you
um
man
it's
nothing as compared to how this has like
skyrocketed us i know i i don't know
it's been unreal and yeah i'm so
grateful to be a part of this franchise
and it's definitely helped me in so many
ways and on top of that too you're also
living the dream out in hawaii
for myself it's crazy i'm literally
doing what i love in hawaii i know the
vacation spot yeah so season two of
doogie come aloha what is your character
going to
be like my character is uh he's a cancer
patient of um dr kame aloha um he's a
he's very i'm trying to find the right
word here adventurous he likes to you
know run out escape jump off waterfalls
you know do whatever he likes to do but
um i'm i'm just having an amazing time
up there it's uh
it's
exactly what you'd expect it to be on
when i'm working i'm well i'm in hawaii
they're like in a hospital bed which is
super comfortable and meg we'll see you
on the season three of high school
musical the musical
how much fun was that it's summer camp
oh it was incredible yeah um being with
everybody especially with matt cornett
who's also in zombies as well um he
working with him was just so much fun
because we just spent a whole summer
together and then all my scenes were
pretty much with him um so it was
awesome and uh you know the cast is just
so incredible
[Music]
best summer ever
one could say the stakes have never been
higher
and one will mistakes have never been
higher you also have the supernatural
spin-off too which is
you know you know you know
something about fandoms and that fandom
is one of the best what was it like
stepping into
that world that universe it was
incredible it's it's an honor and the
fans are so passionate and they love
supernatural so much so there's a
fun kind of pressure coming into it
because we're really trying to make sure
that we you know um really make sure
that the fans are happy and um yeah
we're really really excited to start
filming again and we're really excited
for the fans to see it
oh i'm so sorry
stop helping
what was that that was a demon what is
next for you guys on the bucket list
what is that one thing that you you
really want to check off that's a great
question
uh what three two one oh okay here's the
shadeless plug three two one tango live
action okay this is what we're doing i'm
flynn ryder she's working hey this has
always been our dream all right listen i
didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice
here comes the smolder
and it sounds like you guys have put a
lot of planning in this already
yeah but no i don't know more seriously
like i think i don't know it'd be cool
to be like a superhero or do something a
little bit more horrible than what i've
been doing yeah i just want to lie try
some different things
look at it she has the superhero face
yeah
thank you but i really also could see a
tango live action yeah right for you
i won't be upset if it doesn't happen
i'll just be upset if it happens without
us so we need to make it happen with us
how how do we make it happen i say
because that now i'm invested in this
we'll keep you posted who do we call and
what do we do you have everything laid
out do you have the pitch it sounds
strong so far
now i'm getting nervous i need to polish
it a little bit more before i take it
somewhere yeah we'll figure it out we
got this we can't we can figure this out
yeah i got it yeah we shoot for the moon
right the worst thing that that happens
is we land amongst the stars
[Applause]
exactly you guys congratulations on
everything i'm so happy for you guys if
if you would have told all of us at the
very beginning of zombies here we would
be years later
talking about zombies three would we
have
what would the reaction of it said
you're crazy yeah i definitely would
have but we're here now and i'm loving
it so thanks for having us
of course and y'all
zombies 3 july 15th disney plus don't
miss it